ils ont l'eau courante
on leur apporte à manger ils ont un toit
au dessus de leur tête et le confort
s'arrête là pour ces hommes originaires
du mali ces travailleurs sont sans
papiers
on sait que le coc film a séduit le
monde entier le monde entier s'inquiète
mais nous notre cas c'est un grave c'est
encore autre chose à 273 personnes qui
vivent une centaine de mètres carrés
donc c'est pas c'est pas évident de
vivre dedans mais pour lui parce qu'on a
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix parce qu'on
n'a pas de pouvoir est sûre ça que pour
nous les scores comme ceux-là
si les squatteurs du 138 stalingrad
représente un cas extrême et problèmes
de logement dans le deuxième département
le plus peuplé d'île de france après
paris il plus pauvres au pays sont
monnaies courantes les maladies les
pandémies les maladies infectieuses cd
vrai révélateur des inégalités sociales
c'est ça malheureusement comme toutes
les maladies sa frappe en premier lieu
les populations les plus fragiles et les
plus démunis et c'est ce qui est le cas
cette année
al'annonce 2
du confinement 20% de la population
d'île de france s'est barré en province
allez dans ses résidences secondaires
pour échapper au confinement et avoir
des conditions un peu plus sympa sauf
qu'en seine-saint-denis il n'y a pas de
résidences secondaires
tout le monde est resté donc et vit trop
souvent dans des espaces exigus des
habitations insalubres avec une famille
nombreuse
un cocktail explosif quand la prévention
passe par la distanciation donc ce
département il ya beaucoup d'habitats
dégradées
il ya une maladie qui s'appelle que vous
connaissez peut-être pas aucun vrai
qu'ils s'appellent de saturnisme onguene
hammadi et l'intoxication au plomb et
qui survient dans les logements qui sont
dégradées humide avec la peinture qui
s'écaille que les gosses majeur d'autre
part on a un département aussi à
beaucoup de tuberculose on a de très
nombreux indicateurs péjoratif on a un
taux de diabétiques d'obésité qui est
bien supérieur à la moyenne nationale dr
manuel ans a voulu tester les résidents
du 138 stalingrad cette semaine pour
identifier les porteurs du coronavirus
élise isolé
mais il s'est frappé le nez à la
méfiance du gros le test donc c'est pour
nous diviser nous retrouvent c'est pour
nous disent pâture nous on n'a pas de
dispute chez nous on va remonter et est
resté ensemble solide et avant qu'on
soit réalisé parce qu'en fait la lutte
pour rage et pour la régularisation
parce que pour ces hommes pandémie ou
pas ça demeure l'enjeu principal
après 10 15 ou 20 ans un titre de séjour
la clé d'une vie dont ils ont rêvé de
loin et qui sait peut-être la promesse
du luxe de pouvoir se confiner ici marie
ève bédard radio-canada montreuil